[Music]
after learning about the alkanes which
are the saturated hydrocarbons it's time
for us to know the unsaturated type of
hydrocarbons the first family is that of
alkanes these are the ones having at
least one double bond between the carbon
atoms now is there a formula to
represent these as well yes just like
alkanes even alkenes are represented
with the formula it is cnh2n here as
well n stands for the number of carbon
atoms does the number of hydrogen atoms
in an alkyne will be double the number
of carbon atoms in it that's right
for example the simplest alkyne known to
us is the ethene it has two carbon atoms
and they share a double covalent bond so
the value of n is two so what will be
the number of hydrogen atoms in a theme
based on the formula it is two times n
as n is two we get the number of
hydrogen atoms in ethane as four that
gives us the chemical formula for a
theme as c2h4 similar to ethene all the
other alkenes can be represented using
this simple formula now we are left with
the last family that consists of members
with at least one triple covalent bond
between the carbon atoms these are
referred to as the alkynes we know the
formulae for alkanes and alkenes now and
can you guess what could the formula for
alkynes be it is cnh2n minus two there's
one thing we can surely tell by looking
at the formulae it tells us that for the
same number of carbon atoms alkynes will
have lesser number of hydrogen atoms as
compared to alkanes and alkenes now let
us take an example to understand the
working of this formula as well we
consider the simplest alkyne that is
attained as our example it has two
carbon atoms that share a triple
covalent bond as it has two carbon atoms
the value of n in the formula will be
two
the number of hydrogen atoms will be 2
times 2 minus 2 it gives us the answer
as to two hydrogen atoms
thus the formula for ethene is c2h2
let's quickly review what we learned
hydrocarbons are classified into two
categories saturated and unsaturated
hydrocarbons saturated ones have a
single covalent bond between carbon
atoms and unsaturated ones have at least
one double or triple covalent bond
between carbon atoms alkanes are the
saturated hydrocarbons and their formula
is cnh2n plus two alkenes are
unsaturated hydrocarbons with at least
one double covalent bond their formula
is cnh2n while alkynes are unsaturated
hydrocarbons having at least one triple
bond do you remember the formula yes its
cnh2n minus two let's study the
nomenclature system of hydrocarbons in
the next video
[Music]